Hello everybody and welcome to episode
number 25 of my 1hour flipping
challenge. Today we're just going to be
starting with a 10m start. No category.
Uh but it's something some people have
requested quite a few times. So I
thought I would get around to doing it.
Uh cuz nowadays I start with 30 40 even
50 mil and uh I haven't actually started
with a lower amount in quite a while
because some people would like to know
actually what items you can still flip
with a lower cash stack or 10 mil at
least. And uh I know I'm kind of sound
like [__] today. not feeling that great.
Uh but we're going to record a video for
you guys anyway. And yeah, let's jump
into it. All right, guys. So, we're
going to start with 10 mil. Uh we're not
really limited by items, more just
limited by our cash stack. And let's go.
1 hour. Let's go. Um so, let's just
check our 10 mil just to make sure it's
actually 10. There we go. So, what we're
going to start off is I think a
decanting flip. Um, now I didn't
actually get a chance to check too much
ahead before I did this one, but this
one does seem to have a decent margin on
it. Um, so 273 and 272 is what we're
buying the three dose potion for. And
the four dose potion, I think, was uh
selling for 400. So what that means is
um we can try buying it for this price
here, the high price. So we should
actually buy a couple right away and uh
do 2k of those.
Take off a few of those.
And yeah, let's see how many of these we
actually buy. Okay, so we've actually
bought 656. Pretty good. So, we'll leave
that for now. All right, looks like of
the two, the Renar seed has a bit of a
better margin. Uh, so we'll go ahead and
buy some. That's still 600 GP. Um, B60k
if you buy 100 of these costing us um
2.5 mil. So, not too bad. Uh, we'll buy
them for 25302.
25302. And we'll just start with 100 of
these. All right. Next up, the super
energy potion actually has a pretty good
margin on it as well. Uh we're going to
be buying them for 25.
Actually, same thing. We can buy them
for 2532 and still have a pretty decent
margin. So, we'll do that. Uh 2532 and
uh we'll just go for 2,000. See how many
we actually buy. We'll start with 1k
actually. And uh from 1k we're going to
buy about 500. So, pretty good. I guess
we could go decant these quickly. Um,
next up, a good one is some runes are
always pretty good. Law runes. Let's try
law runes. Um, yeah, law runes have a 5
GP margin on it. Why not? We'll just go
do uh 9k. Uh, next up, we could do some
blood runes. 230 to 235. Pretty good.
We're going to do another 9k blood runes
or so. And that's going to be most of
our money. Now, we haven't done any uh
quicker flips or slower flips yet. Uh,
because we're still trying to find a
good item under 10 mil. Um, we might try
to get one of those in there once uh at
least these sell off. All right, so uh
we bought all our law runes for 181
pretty quick. The reason I'm not buying
10k exactly is because if you buy 10,000
uh you won't be able to recheck the item
after. Um so now we bought for 181. Uh
that's a 6GP margin pretty easy. Pop
them in for 187. So we bought them uh
we're selling them for 1683 and we
bought them for 1629. That is um 40
50k in profit. Not too bad. Um all the
uh Renar seeds came through as well. All
right. So we're not selling these for a
huge margin unfortunately only for 520
25 519. Um but we'll just move on to
another item if this one's not working
very well. All right. So we've sold off
all the uh law runes. That is uh I don't
know 50 60k profit. And we bought the
blood runes for one 236. Now I may have
I insta bought them. So uh we'll
hopefully uh get two GP on them. still
sell for 238. I mean, the time it took
for this to flip, it would definitely be
worth it. That's 30k in like a minute.
Uh, but I'm not sure if we can actually
sell them for that price, but we'll uh
give it a try. All these super energy
potion fours have sold as well. All
right, so we've sold off all the
snapjack seeds. Only 20 30k profit on
that, so not great. Uh, but we also sold
the blood runes off for a uh 20k profit.
Pretty happy with that. So, we'll have
to find a couple more items cuz we're
pretty much back up to our initial 10
mil. All right. Uh so with some of our
money, we're going to put an offer in
for a magic fang. I checked the price
and it looks uh roughly like it's around
25 uh 40 or something like that. So 2545
and uh we'll just go for the one for
now. And hopefully that will buy. Uh
next we should definitely find another
quick item. Maybe the cosmic rune.
Cosmic rune actually has a 4 GP margin
which is pretty decent to do. 9500
cosmic runes. All right, we got a magic
fang already at 2545. I think we're
going to try to sell it for 50k profit
at 255
2599.
Uh that would leave us yeah with a 50k
profit roughly.
Not bad. Um actually we got some more
super energies. That's pretty nice. Any
more of these that we buy at this price
is just amazing to be honest. Um all our
energy potions have sold. Uh, not really
sure how much we got on that, but still
a decent amount. All right, we've
decanted uh some of these super energies
that we bought earlier. Um, we're going
to sell them for 3670.
Pretty decent.
3670. Uh, we'll find another item and
then we'll actually calculate how much
we're getting on all of this cuz it's a
really good margin right now. All right,
we bought another magic fang. Uh, the
other one hasn't sold yet for $25.99, so
we're probably going to wait it out a
little bit longer. Uh, but we'll toss it
in over here and hope it sells. All
right. Uh, snap dragon seeds look like a
500 GP margin would be pretty good. 3122
and we'll do 100. And that's going to be
pretty much all our money. We really
need to sell these fangs off, but um
probably lower them down if they don't
sell soon. Okay, looks like the super
taxs have a decent margin on them. So,
we'll buy some cuz they're so cheap and
we only have about 700k left. So
hopefully we can buy some of these uh
three dose uh super taxs for 500 and uh
we'll just use the rest of our money
and 1300. Sure, that's fine. Uh actually
all these snapdragon seeds are pretty
much all through. So we'll go ahead and
pop those in to sell as well. Okay, so
we've gone to the good old GE tracker
and we're finding an item to help maybe
save this 1 hour. And uh we did sell all
the Snapdragon seeds. Now that's not a
huge profit. Only going to be uh
actually not too bad. 70 or 80k. Um, but
I think what we're going to use our
money for is the Saridoman dehide boots.
Um, looks like it has a very good
margin, almost 100k for the price. Way
better than these other items. And I
trade a decent amount, too. So, we're
going to buy them for about uh 1.2 mil.
And we'll go for two and see how that
goes. All right. So, we actually got one
only after a couple minutes. I was kind
of excited for this because it looks
like there's um I don't know 4 500
traded a day and per half an hour
10 15. So I think we should be able to
buy maybe three or four of these even
and uh yeah. So we'll pull that out.
We'll try pump it in for
Yeah. Um 1270 or something maybe.
1270K. That's a nice amount of profit.
Hopefully we can actually sell that off
and the rest of these these magic fangs.
Bad idea. Only getting like a 19k
margin. Maybe reduce them down a bit
more even. All right, we bought another
Sarah and dehide boot for 125. So
hopefully we can actually sell them for
1270. Um think I'm just going to double
down on this. Just put another offer in
1205. We can only afford one right now.
Yeah. And hopefully these actually sell
off because that's a decent profit and
we kind of need it. All right, there we
go. We have sold both of the boots for
1270. That is a nice profit. That is uh
65k on both.
That's 120k. We're definitely going to
get more of these. Uh bump that up to uh
three of those maybe
Sarah. And the good thing about this
item and why I would actually recommend
it is actually has a buying limit of 70.
Uh so much higher than most rare items.
125 and do three. All right, we got
another boot and then we'll pop it in
for 1270 to sell again. Hopefully we can
sell that off quickly. I think we're
going to try the um Gothics boot as
well. Kind of the same deal. Oh, we got
another one coming in at 12:05. Popped
in to 1270 for now.
1270. All right, so we bought all of the
Saromomen dehy boots. Uh they're coming
in pretty quickly and the Saridomomen
Dhi boots have sold for 1270. 70k game
profit. Uh we'll condense these now.
Screw it. uh pop them in for 1270 as
well. Okay, so we insta sold the magic
fangs. They were doing more harm than
good. Uh we only lost 23k on each one,
so not too bad. Uh but that 46k loss is
going to free up a lot more money. I
think it's more important. We still have
20 minutes left and we'll try to flip a
couple more items. All right, one item
that I used to do a lot was the dragon
pickaxe. Uh, looks like we can buy for
about 303
76 8
whatever. And uh, we can afford two.
Perfect. And hopefully we can get a 40
or 50k margin on that. They trade even
more than the seridan dehide boot. So
hopefully it won't take too long to buy.
All right, we have a pickaxe coming
through at 3038 as well as a serotonin
dehide boot sale 1270. Uh, so we'll pull
out the pickaxe at 3038 and we're going
to sell it for maybe 3068 or something.
And that will be 30k on those. Not as
good by any means, but uh hopefully
should trade even more in these. All
right, we have another Seridomomen Dhigh
boot flip coming in at 270K. And that's
another decent amount of profit. Uh
16 minutes. Yeah, we'll go ahead and buy
another one at 12:05. And the pickaxe
has come through. Oh, another one came
through. 3038 and we're trying to sell
them, but they're not actually selling.
So, we're going to reduce them even more
and maybe down to 3058.
Not a big margin on those, but uh what
can you do? And uh yeah, hopefully we
can actually flip a couple more of these
cuz none of the other items have worked
too well. And we got 16 minutes left.
All right, we have another one coming
through. These are flipping so quickly
right now. Uh 1270 we just sold it for.
Um
yeah. Oh, and there's a pickaxe coming
through at 3058. Nice. Uh, they're just
coming through so quickly. We're going
to go ahead and buy maybe another one of
these. And hopefully we can actually
sell some more cuz that is
single-handedly carrying this hour. I
was probably minutes away from just
giving up and restarting or doing
another category. But, um, yeah, luckily
we found this item near the end, which
is working extremely well. All right.
Um, so we're going to do a death rune
flip because uh we have 10 minutes left
and we can't really think of anything
else to do with the rest of this money.
Uh, go for 9k of those. It's going to
come to about 2.7 mil. Uh, we have
bought two more of the Saratom and
dehide sets. Amazing. The fact that this
doesn't have a buying limit is just
insane as well. Well, it does have a
buying limit, but it's for our purposes.
Uh, not going to affect us. Um, and 1270
looks good. Uh, the death runes are
coming through. Super energies will
probably end up dumping at the end, but
we might as well recheck that. And the
dragon pickaxes are quite a bit slower
than I thought they were going to be.
Uh, so kind of interesting. All right,
we sold our dragon pickaxe. Uh, not a
huge margin on that.
It was only 20k.
Not awful. 40k. Uh, the risk probably
not worth the reward in that case, but
we did it anyway. All right, we're doing
another seed flip since uh we only have
10 minutes left. Uh but it's kind of
tough to
actually use our money when it comes
down to less than a sixth of the time
remaining. Uh but we'll do it anyway. Uh
buy it for 3111
and I go for another 100 seeds. I think
that's what we bought before. So we'll
have to check. But hopefully we can
actually buy and sell these in time. If
not, we're probably going to ditch on
it. All right, we're down to 7 minutes
left. So we're going to pull everything
out uh that is currently buying. Uh, so
that is the snap dragon seeds, the death
runes, uh, which did all sell pretty
well. Um, and yeah, that's pretty much
it. Pull that out. Pop these in here for
30, uh, 313.
And the, uh, Snapdragon seeds, we'll
recheck cuz they do I guess they're
still selling.
Yeah, 31497. That's a decent margin.
31497.
And hopefully we can sell this last
boot. I think I'm going to drop it down
because I kind of got the feeling we got
undercut cuz they were coming in so
quickly. Uh so
12 64. How about
sounds good? And yeah, we'll just wait
for everything to sell and then we'll
see how much we actually made. All
right, guys. We sold our last uh dehide
boot for 1264. Only a 6k uh less profit,
I guess. So, not too bad. And we sold
all the death runes and all the snap all
the snap dragons. Okay, we're pretty
much done, guys. We just have to sell
the last couple bit of uh super energies
here. Hopefully, they're even sold by
the time I just dump these vials.
Maybe not. Death rune or lava run sold.
Okay, guys. I'm impatient. Uh whatever.
Oh my god, we sold one more. Okay, it's
only going to be like a K we're missing
out on, so it's not a huge deal. Uh four
potions. We'll just dump those and get
our 13k or so. And we'll just stop the
timer now. There's no point in waiting
longer.
So, when I first started this hour, I
almost gave up. This one was pretty
tough for some reason. I just the
motivation wasn't there. Uh, this
happens a lot where the first half an
hour goes awful and then I just give up
and then start another another try when
the first half of the hour goes well.
Uh, and then sometimes it reverses.
Sometimes the first hour is good, the
last hour sucks. But it's hard to stay
motivated when no flips are really
working. But luckily near the end there,
we found a good item that was under 10
mil and had a good margin on it. So,
let's see how much we made uh with a 10
mil start in one hour. And it's looking
like 845k. That's actually extremely
good. Uh if we compare um to what I
start with, say 50 mil um that is uh
pretty on par almost with what I
normally get. 800 to one and a half mil
or something is generally the uh the
range of profit I get. So that's really
good for only starting with 10 mil.
Obviously the best item by far was that
Saridoman dehide boots which I've now
learned actually has a limit of eight on
it. Uh I'm not sure why I thought it was
70. I think the old uh wiki said it was
70, but on G Tracker says it's eight,
which I would be uh more inclined to
believe. And uh yeah, I hope you guys
enjoyed. I know this wasn't my most
stellar comedy comedy commentary. Oh
god. Um, I'm not feeling that great and
uh but I still wanted to uh record a
video for you guys. So hopefully you can
understand me mostly cuz my voice sounds
like [__] And uh I will see you guys in
the next episode.
[Music]